how much money do you really need
to start shooting videos at home
zero you heard me right you may have
heard about fancy cameras and fancy
lighting and
great equipment but you don't need any
of that to start shooting videos at home
the only thing you really need is the
determination to start
[Music]
remember that it's more important to
have great content than to have a huge
expensive production set let's first
talk about the simplest setup possible
to start shooting videos at home you
just need your smartphone
because nowadays all smartphones come
with good quality cameras
but is that it let me give you just four
tips that will help you create great
videos
first good lighting and you don't need
fancy lights for that
the best lighting out there is natural
light or sunlight
also remember that if there is one light
source then it should be in the front of
your face
it shouldn't be behind you
how do we know if the lighting is good
or not this for instance looks good
and this not so good also if you're
using a board especially a white board
make sure there are no reflections seen
on the board to avoid this
you could just place the light
diagonally across and not straight
towards the board
second good sound quality make sure
there's no background noise when you're
shooting videos
turn off your tv close your windows and
try your best to eliminate
all external sources of sound another
common problem when it comes to sound
is echo the best way to avoid the echo
is to make sure you're not in a
completely empty room
echo occurs mainly due to reflection of
sound
how can you reduce the echo you could
have carpeted floors
you could fill the room with furnishings
and you could also use thick curtains to
cover the walls and windows
if you want even better sound quality
then you could possibly invest some
money in buying a good external mic
let me give you an example this is how
it sounds with an external phone mic
and this is how it sounds with an
inbuilt phone mic
third good framing framing is all the
things your audience can see in the
frame of your video
that not only includes you but also your
background
don't be too close to the camera or too
far away from it
and have a simple clean background
without any distractions
treat the video as if you're taking an
actual class for your students
in person you'd want no distractions
whatsoever right
and lastly the stability of your
smartphone your smartphone needs to be
very stable when it's recording a video
you could buy a tripod as simple tripods
are available for cheap
but if you don't wish to invest in one
you could use books on a table
and then use your laptop for stability
now there's a possibility that you want
to go one step further
to create better quality videos using
some advanced equipment
what i'm using right now is a dslr
camera on a tripod
now let me show you two pictures on the
screen one taken with a cell phone and
the other with a dslr
i'm sure you notice the difference a
better camera will give you
sharper and crisp images unlike your
smartphone camera
now you can also use a zoom lens along
with it which will help you capture
zoomed in video without making the video
look grainy
the dslr camera also has a sensor that
is far superior to the sensor in your
smartphone camera
that means it can handle many more
lighting situations relative to your
smartphone camera
i'm also using a good wireless mic here
which gives a crisp sound quality
and also eliminates the noise around
here's how it would sound with a regular
mic
and here's how it sounds with the
current mic i'm using
you should note that the recordings that
are generated using your dslr camera
are stored in an sd card which is
present inside the camera
these recordings can then be transferred
to your laptop or tablet
using a card reader now some of you
might be wondering
what if there are some parts in the
video which you want to cut
this part is called editing the video
and you will not believe how easy it is
to do this
there are plenty of free editing tools
available out there that make it so easy
for you to cut parts of your video
you could also shoot many bite-sized
videos and merge them together to create
a longer video
all of this and lots more can be done
easily using editing tools
i'll share more details about editing
tools in the description of this video
so how can you begin my suggestion would
be to start off using your smartphone
and once you start uploading videos
consistently
the love you get from your audience
would automatically make you invest in
better equipment
so what are you waiting for shoot your
first video and share it with the world
in the next video i will show you how
you can upload your videos to your
youtube channel
see you there
[Music]